action dave you're listening to the
dollop on the all things comedy network
this is a
buy
weekly
oh [ __ ] how are we gonna do an extra one
a week great american history podcast
where each week i
sunglasses where
man who likes
peanut butter
lover of dogs ugh dave anthony i bet i
think the last two are related from
american history
to my
enemy gareth reynolds who has no idea
what the topic is going to be about and
i'm not your enemy
you're right but you are not my friend
that is not the case
[Music]
you're uh someone who hurts
hurts you
i'm very good to you
and very understanding to you you attack
me you are full of outbursts and rage
and oddity
and i hang in there and i try
to hold and hug no you are a psychopath
you
fight no and fight no because you'll
text crazy things never has happened
can't wait to see my honey pot tomorrow
i didn't say honey pot whatever you said
i said special boy yeah say it's weird
and there's nothing wrong with that it
is not normal for you to do that to me
what to call you my special boy yes it's
my special guy i can't wait to see you
my special guy yeah it's like it's like
what a dad would say to a kid but like
the kid would be like six and then you
said don't talk like this anymore and i
said sorry my boy and you said no and i
said my sugar pot yes there you go so
that is all just me being nice no it's
you just for whatever you're being angry
and aggressive you could be doing other
stuff
you'll just take so much time to send
80 gifts
of like some bear like spreading its ass
while hearts fly out of it and you'll be
like i'm just gonna do this for like the
whole night so all night i'm just gonna
text them these
that's what i'm gonna make my night
about my night is gonna be devoted to
like
as soon as he replies to the gift from
an hour ago i hit him with another one
right away
you do realize this just encourages me
there's no there's no stopping any of it
how upset you are no there's no stopping
any of it
doesn't matter if i encourage you or not
you're you're a tornado it doesn't mean
you happen
do you see there's a little tornado in
england
no it's fine all right let's start
you want to announce uh well you can
announce your dates but i'll say that we
are
going on a tour in september you can go
to dogpodcast.com
uh to get the ticket links but we are
going to
get to wise guys in las vegas september
14th september 16th we'll be at wise
guys in salt lake city we'll be at the
high plains comedy festival saturday
september 18th at the paramount theater
september 22nd stand up live in phoenix
arizona november 5th we'll be at the
palace of fine arts in san francisco
november 6th we'll be at the crest
theater in sacramento and december 10th
will be at the observatory in north park
san diego and australia we won't be
joining you uh and then as far as i go
dave i will be at the spokane comedy
club thursday august 26th then oh wait
this will have happened this will have
happened i'll be at the milwaukee improv
this weekend
friday september 3rd through saturday
september 4th i'll be at the stress
factory in new jersey saturday september
10th through september 11th
then i'll be at the stress factory in
bridgeport connecticut friday october
1st through saturday october 2nd and
then we should also mention dave that we
have a live virtual
reverse
dollop on september 2nd thursday
september 2nd we have a
live
reverse dollop that's right i
gareth reynolds will be reading a story
to dave anthony a man who's filming me
with his phone like a prick right now
for some stupid reason content hashtag
content get out of my face it's
it's i'm putting up a thing on the
instagram about um promoting the show
for
reverse dollop i was going to put this
up online for people if there's like a
promo it's really good really good you
did a good job really good uh we will be
uh doing a reverse dollop that's right i
will be telling dave's story that is uh
september 2nd thursday september 2nd you
can go to looped live to get tickets to
that looped live the show will be at 6
p.m pacific standard time
all right
we done no that was upsetting it's tough
ah it's hard
i try to be professional yeah you really
really do
so
keep going professional guy
hey super professional guy why don't you
do your part
come on
the part where you flip me off
i didn't know what was happening let's
talk let's talk through it i don't want
to talk through it
do ads after
yeah i'll put them in later
i forgot the music too yeah we'll do the
we haven't done the music in the past
two episodes then but you know does
anybody even care anymore like you don't
everybody hates us
what are you talking what's happening to
you
oh [ __ ]
just put focus dave okay my name is gary
my name's gary is it for fun and this is
not gonna become the tickling podcast
okay this is like adam and a five-part
confession
now hit him with a puppy
you both present sick arguments don't
sleep down hippo that's like that
hip-hop action part
hi gabby
all right
we played the music all right it feels
like you feel good about it i feel good
about it
get your hands in
is that much pain what because of the
finger i'm sorry i gave you the fingers
1791.
george pollard
what what dude the overlord
was born dave it was the year of our
lord nantucket massachusetts oh right
the tuck
sure yeah i call it ducksville
oh [ __ ] that's not gonna work
there you go um his father was a ship's
captain okay and what's his name uh
george pollard okay george pollard jr
okay
um and uh so this is the time when
hunting sperm whale for oil was a huge
industry like i mean they it
to put it in like modern day terms they
would get vc funding
right ships to go murder whales like it
was and then turn the whales into oil
turn them into oil as you're supposed to
how much oil do you get out of a whale i
mean barrels tons of oil yeah so you
turn that blubber into oil and yeah
barrels is that where we're headed when
we've suck all the
oil out of this we'll eventually turn
people into oil i'm amazed we haven't
figured out how to do that yet but we
will we'll figure out how to turn people
into oil that'll be and then you can
sell yourself for like 50 bucks when you
die and that'll be interesting
when you can finally throw your own hand
into the gas tank that's right that's
when i'll be like this country's right
let's do it this worked
so uh nantucket is at the center of the
whale you know murder um scene sure
he started working on ships as a teen
and when he was 23 he had served on the
ship essex for four years
as both second mate and then first mate
and then he was made captain
in
1819 okay so he's a super young
yeah captain he's 18.
go ahead
[Applause]
so he is preparing to take the ship on a
long long trip to the pacific ocean to
do some whaling in august okay
it's gonna be hard to bring a whale back
to shore uh no you don't you they they
deal with it right there on the boat oh
really yeah you process them they put it
into barrels on that actual ship yeah
crazy
george oh sorry the crew was uh 21 men
okay
george's 17 year old cousin owen coffin
was on board
oh no it's the other one c-o-f-f-i-n
darker
let me out
george promised his aunt that he would
keep owen safe
he's like i got this this is you can't
make that promise i'll do it i'll try
real hard what could go wrong on a boat
in the middle of the
ocean fine should be fine we've really
worked out most of the kinks
yeah so um
so they there's eight men from nantucket
and then there's a bunch of guys from
cape cod and boston the nantucket guys
are super experienced the other guys
pretty inexperienced but they talk so
much [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
dude
i i know more in my pinky finger about
finding like whale oil then you know
when you're whole stupid what are you
talking about you're an idiot you're a
[ __ ] idiot wait we're supposed to be
on the same team yeah that's right yeah
hey hey
miss my guy
[Laughter]
special guy yeah
uh huh no
uh so the man
the man the men from nantucket called
the other guys green hands right okay
so that's it because it's an 87-foot
long ship nice pretty big yeah so it's
set sail on august 12
1918 on uh two and a half year voyage
just catching whales and killing whales
yeah wow okay
things went south in about two days okay
that's good that's good yeah so that's
good
the essex got hit by a squall
so squall giant wind comes through
sometimes there's lightning and rain but
it's like a mostly a wind thing that
really [ __ ] you up okay
uh it was knocked down
onto its side the boat and then and you
do not want to be doing that no they're
supposed to stay up if buts are sideways
i guess with the sail yeah you want to
get the sails wet
that makes a lot of sense so it almost
sinks
they lost two whale boats so right so
little boat they have
there's like a 27 foot there's you know
25 maybe got decide right that you get
in to go hunt the whales and then you
yeah super cool uh so
uh the third
or third whale boat was damaged
the top gallant
sale
uh was destroyed which is like the the
the top square one right up there baby
sale yeah baby sell up top okay that
will go with that first baby sale
babysitter
um so there's the mama papa's and then
so
they also had issues not just from the
squall but also
the officers had miscalculated good uh
and also because the crew had little
experience we're still on land
idiots
[Laughter]
we're in boston
uh but they created a little experience
so they didn't turn fast enough stuff
like that sure right so george thinks
the damage is too much and he's like we
should go back to nantucket and fix this
[ __ ] and start over again but the first
and second mates
talk them into continuing on
going to the azores where they could get
hopefully more whale boats so they've
lost like two of their
hunting boats essentially they've lost
the sale
and people are like we'll be fine yeah
we'll be all right okay we got this yeah
okay
so george does not turn back and he
keeps sailing sure sure shh
yeah it's a whale sale now
uh they landed on the island of floros
on august 30th and they got uh some
supplies of vegetables they got some
pigs
okay but no boats sure there were no
boats to be had right were they
expecting to find boats well they were
open to five boats yeah so they thought
they'd go to this land and they'd be
like a boat store yeah but boat shop
okay
damn it another island with just pigs
and no boat shops
damn
i gotta say i'm thinking about opening
up a boat shop here it's very strange
how this started as a whaling expedition
and now we're hunting boats
so they sailed on and they stopped at
the cape of verdes where any boats
okay i know well now they see a whaler a
whaling boat like their boat okay and it
is it is stuck on the beach oh this is
perfect right so
i told you we'd find a boat i mean that
guy's lucky yeah three two two boom new
boat three guys come out in a whaling
boat okay and they're like everyone else
bailed when the ship got stuck everyone
left except for us
and so they bought the whale boat from
them
the odds are just and they got some more
pigs
jesus very good ver it worked out really
well i would be in the back like we're
gonna die because of this move yeah so
we have a new boat and a bunch more
bacon yeah hey
so they sail on and uh they round cape
horn at the bottom of south america
about five weeks later okay
and on the eight that's on the 18th of
december okay
and they did some whaling off of chile
they killed eight sperm whale nice and
converted them into 250 barrels of oil
so there you go that's how many that's
nature yeah that is nature that's nature
that's finally nature's understanding
actually they actually by the way why
couldn't that be the oil we spill in the
ocean wouldn't that be great the whale
oil yeah it'd just be a little bit
better than that maybe a little bit
better black tar oil that we then pour
corrects it on
the bottom it's pretty good also it's
really good obviously for the ocean yeah
uh so at this point they need more food
so they stopped well i wish we had some
whale
really hit the spot huh
it's a sludge now
so they stop at hood and charles islands
in the galapagos okay
and
now remember the huge tortoises from the
darwin yep so there's a bunch of those
cruising around okay so they're like
perfect and they grab 300 of those just
the right amount from uh from hood
island and then they go to charles
island
and they get 60 more sure now after
they've grabbed 60
they have to uh
well first of all they can here's the
great thing about these turtles is they
can stay alive without food or water for
like a year
so it's just like this thing living
there that you can crack open every once
in a while
yeah well it's so strange to me like how
in this time
it feels like you would be much more
connected to land and nature and more
understanding of other beings it feels
like now like i mean we are worse now
because we do it in this like
we don't even know where the [ __ ] the
food comes from you know but i would
just imagine that in some way you would
be like that is a that is torture that
is you are creating a torturous
situation it is absolute torture but
it's it's religion which gives
them the belief that they land
everything is for them yes yes yes
so um
so
they only got 60 from the second island
instead of more because there was a
helmsman named thomas
uh
chapel and he thought it would be really
funny he's pulling a prank
and he lights some underbush on fire
okay
that's a fun can't pull that prank
anymore and the underbrush just goes up
and pretty soon the island is burning
i'm goofing
hello
it's a classic fire prank guys all right
now here's the thing with my prank
it is unending
this is a terrible nightmare prank my
prank ruins this entire island you
should see your faces it's worth
everything i mean the other thing was
gonna i was gonna do is i have a pack of
gum and when you take out a piece of
garment like it like stings your face
permission to live on your ship but
instead i burn the island i've burned my
home horribly
for your benefit
so they have to run
and they grab what tortoises they have
and they get back on the boat and it's
pig dry season so did you guys uh notice
something different about the island
well i see it's on fire every part of
it's on fire was that us or was that a
tortoise um that was me i was
having a bit of a goof oh fun
that's fun
and you remember your first mate yes i
took his heart out as a bit of a goof
goof
you're very bad at pranks
it's very i
have an angle i'm working and it's not
good fantastic it's not good i've put a
big hole in the ship oh jesus you should
see the look on your mouth
it's a ghast i would only label it as a
ghast
so yeah so
the fire just keeps burning funny quit
being so negative and uh
it just sweeps across the island so the
next day they leave because the island's
on fire
and george didn't george doesn't know
who lit it they didn't tell him at this
time and so he's just he wants to kill
whoever did it like he's furious because
all these the [ __ ] everything's dying
yes yes he's an island is burned
so um they head back out and they go
back to killing whales and they kill
whales for a few months can you believe
the way they damage nature just for
nothing
now let's go yank a bunch of these
whales out for oil huh boys let's get
some lamps lit let's go
uh they did very well it's a very
prosperous voyage they're kicking ass
they're killing a lot of
animals they would harpoon the whales
in the whale boats right a guy would sit
up front and harpoon it
and then they would hold on to the rope
or whatever and it it would drag they
would just wait until it tired out
water ski out yeah well they called it
nantucket's lay rides and they would
they would that's just right
it really for me it's great because it
brings up christmas which i love yeah
yeah yeah
um and then it would tire out and then
then they'd have it right uh on november
20th 1920 they saw a pot of whales and
the guy at the mass said literally
literally yelled quote
there she blows oh so that was the thing
was that
that's an actual saying that's what they
did that's what they were talking about
yeah
so they lowered down the whale boats
three whale boats the first mate owen
chase who was 23 was in one
and he harpooned a whale
but the whale not was not so into it he
was like i don't actually enjoy this the
whale did not understand he did not like
the big metal thing going into his body
does the whale not understand that it's
a sacrifice for oil oil no he didn't he
didn't get that nature's always seemed
to resist us it's not that way it's not
this is better for everybody yeah take a
second this is the this is the lord's
path sometimes you just have to make a
sacrifice just send your kids back to
school thank you
so uh oh nice try [ __ ]
nice try [ __ ]
yeah yeah let's stay focused jerk
uh so
the whale's on to it and the whale turns
and hits the boat with his tail
now that is bad
well it depends who you're rooting for
i'm rooting whale 100 that's good oh
great because he knocks the boat uh
boat over it has a big hole in it
they managed to get over and plugged the
hole with their jackets and then
and then head back to the
to the essex while bailing water out and
they make it okay the other two boots
the jackets weren't so lucky no the
jackets are
very wet
sorry
i'll be okay
so the other two boats keep going george
is in one of the other so the way it
works is the three whaling boats the the
first mate the second mate and the
captain go in those okay um so george is
in one of those but by the way that's so
different now by the way like you'd be
like um yeah you you and you you guys
you're what we call heroes you know the
dangerous thing that's your job your
front line whalers i'm staying here with
the pie we will clap so much when you're
done
so
so he's back on board he chases back on
board the essex and he looks out at the
ocean
then he sees a very large whale
it's about 85 feet long okay
lying quote quietly in the distance yes
and it's facing the essex you see okay
so
almost like the whale's like i don't
trust you i uh i kept my eye on you yeah
chase quote he spouted two or three
times and then disappeared
in less than two or three seconds he
came up again yes whale about the length
of the ship off and made directly for us
yeah at the rate of about three knots
that's a lot of nuts huh it's hard to do
oh hey i'll tell you there's so many
nuts you might want to get new laces
so
chase gives the order to turn the ship
to avoid him to not get hit head-on i
love the idea that you're like we now
need to run from the whales we're now
running from the whales
[Music]
there's a reverse thing going on here
they will turn us into oil let's move
quote the words were scarcely out of my
mouth before he came down upon us with
full speed yes and struck the ship with
his head oh yes he gave such uh such an
appalling and tremendous jar as nearly
threw us all on our faces so he hits the
boat [ __ ] hard so this is a whale
who's like i don't take [ __ ] i'm not
into what you guys are doing with the
whole killing us thing not cool
so the crew
they can't believe what happened like
this is just totally not something that
occurs sure
and the whale
passes under the ship grazing the
underside and he comes up on the other
side i expect him to talk pretty soon
and he goes
hey [ __ ] yeah yeah
dude
maybe you [ __ ] with the wrong whale
i'll be humpback
so
the whale then sits there for a minute
he's just kind of laying on top of the
water
and chase chase thought it was stunned
from the collision like he hit himself
so hard he just kind of
and then the whale headed off
now the whale had made a hole in the
ship right
and chase
there they blow chase tells him to get
the pumps going
he looks at the damage he comes back up
top
because he's gonna signal the whale
boats and he looks out and he sees the
whale again
yes
apparently in convulsions
on the top of the water about 100 rods
to leeward
he was enveloped in the foam of the sea
that is continual and violent thrashing
about in the water had created around
him and i could distinctly see him smite
his jaws together as if distracted with
rage and fury
that's a lot of projection to put whales
mad
i mean is that
okay because when you say convulsions it
feels like the whale is having reaction
to like head heading the boat it sounds
like he's he's saying that the whale is
out there like
like a bull snorting and [ __ ]
so
the whale seems still really pissed
well let's set up the apology vessel
oh boy
yeah so mad whale so
mad whale's my skateboard line
by the way
check out manwhale.org
com thank you
and then the whale moved across
the bow of the ship very quickly
the ship's in bad shape so at this point
chase is like the ship's lost like it's
taken so much damage
but he he still says keep the pumps
going so we have time
to get whatever you need to get off the
boat
and he lowers
two boats in the water in preparation
for abandoning the essex
and a crew member remember the crew
yells quote here he is he is making for
us again oh god damn this is a great
whale
the whale is about a hundred rods right
in front of the ship and he's coming
fast
whale
chase said he was coming the junior sail
of wales
chase said he was coming with quote
tenfold fury and vengeance that's
amazing he hit the ship again
and smashed a hole in the bow
and then the whale took off and was
never seen again
they're a thousand miles because he is
so busy like
at the base of the ocean accepting
awards
and uh whale of the air no big surprise
here
if whales had done this from the
beginning there would never be any oh i
mean i just you i mean i am at the point
where i just crave
the animal revolt instead of the nature
revolt you know
so they're a thousand miles from land
and chase
he orders him to stop pumping and for
each man to get what he can and get what
he needs it's great that his name chase
and he just completely lost the chance
he did not chase
the steward goes below deck and grabs
two navigators and the captain and
chases trunks
there let's go for a swim i need all my
things i have a little knitty hat i have
these um kind of flowery trunks that i
would love to wear for a quick dip do
you know it's like a it's like it looks
it's like a gun handle but you grab it
and then it it has a vice grip and it
you can pick it up
it's a grabber grabber i have one of
those i need a grabber i didn't know the
name it's a grabber
i have a fly swatter shaped like charlie
brown
that's uh what else do i
there need my globe
um
ball waxer
yes make sure to get the thing i wax my
nuts with
i have other stuff um
some yarn oh the puzzle oh yeah what the
puzzle
i love that puzzle uh there's a game of
yahtzee in there too my butt pillow
his bottom pillow yep
we have other stuff yes
a lot of bottom stuff honestly if you're
comfortable grabbing the bottom stuff
can we give you a litany of items we'd
like from the bottom drawers there's a
secret area there's a whole thing we
have for bottom stuff
so uh
that stuff's put in the boat chase grabs
two compasses so they have two
navigators which basically sounds like a
map right um they got two compasses
now water is just [ __ ] pouring in at
this point sure yeah no whales
head-butted to the boat twice all the
men get in the whale boat and they push
off and then the essex just falls over
sideways in the water okay just how it
started
chase quote not a word was spoken for
several minutes by any of us all
appeared to be bound in a spell of
stupid consternation so uh
that whale was mighty huh yeah that
i feel like this was a bad idea this uh
business we got into
it's a wild wild whale out there [ __ ]
up well
you guys remember that yeah yeah yeah
when the whale uh no it's gonna be hard
to forget yeah yeah yeah
yeah
anyway we're not on the boat
we're on little boats wait was that a
prank nope no that was the fire oh all
right okay yeah that was funny yeah oh
god chappie you remember when you said
the
oh did you set up the whale thing no
ta-da
i did it
so the other criminal not grabbed
anything and they just basically had the
clothes that was on them we were
grabbing stuff
we did another three we're gonna go grab
a bunch of this i got the charlie brown
uh flyswatter oh cool
my jacket's filling the hole in the
essex so
now the two whale boats returned with
george and the second mate and uh one of
the men in george's boat yelled quote oh
my god where's the ship
hey dumbass
jesus
laid it on a little thick aren't you
george is speechless quote he was so
completely overpowered with the
spectacle before him that he sat down in
his boat pale and speechless
he asked what happened and chase
responded quote well we have been stoved
by a whale
stove means to like
smash a big hole into
sure
it's it's boat guys i'm gonna start
using that yeah stove do you mind if i
stove your door
man i stole it through here ma'am no
hey
can i stove the glass no with my body no
let me stove through you
not through me well like you get a drink
later and we'll stove yeah
now we're on all right
after a few minutes george
said uh they should get some food out of
the essex
and so they broke through with hatchets
because that now it's like so it's like
the top is like right so they have to go
through the sort of cap size so there's
like we'll go through the bottom they
found 600 pounds of hard bread that
wasn't wet
and they got as much fresh water as they
could carry which is in kegs
each man had about 65 gallons of water
okay good amount so that's a lot of
water yeah quote we also got
from one of the lockers a musket a small
canister of powder a couple of files two
rasps
and two
pounds of boat nails and a few turtles
oh those turtles are like wait what no
we want to live [ __ ] really we live
here i was on an island
now i'm in the ocean only temporarily
some of the men
being inexperienced didn't really get
how horrible of a situation there so
this uh happens every time is this part
of the deal like what happens to you
guys all the time
when does the uh nobody told me that
whales were uh like that yeah no i never
seen it but that was funny i mean if you
think about it very funny [ __ ] that
guy was not kidding around right when
are we getting picked up yeah what's the
pickup time
do we have another essex
are there two
a couple of crewmen slept very
peacefully that night um what i just out
there laying in the boat and having it
sleep
nobody back then ever slept in a good
place
that's true fair enough
well i'm gonna go to the ocean and nap
[Laughter]
chase however said he didn't have the
words to describe how horrible the
situation i like that he's still like
it's um
[Music]
and then boop boop
okay big big thank you he go smashing
thank you i'm gonna crush your head uh
oil from him no
so the next morning they took sails off
the ship and put them on the boat so
each boat has a little sail that's cute
uh each boat has two masks they built
two masks and these are like 27 feet
long yeah
i mean it's decent size that's probably
good i mean the sails big yeah yeah
they look at the navigators and
um
the nearest land or the
marquesas islands and then the society
islands george wants to go to them okay
but the crew
thought that there were
savages and cannibals on the island who
would eat them okay and so they talked
george out of going to the islands okay
that's gonna be a big mistake okay
[Music]
it's a really bad call where was that
what would have awaited them no because
other people went there a couple years
later and they were just like hey man we
can give you food until someone picks
you up right okay so okay so they decide
they're not gonna go to the pit stop
island
and they're gonna they're gonna head for
peru
okay
i don't know how many miles away it's
like a thousand miles away okay so
compared to like whatever 100 or
something so a lot farther right yeah
um so
they could use the sails to catch the
trade winds and then hopefully they'd be
spotted by a ship out there i just can't
get over the whale still i yeah no you
shouldn't the greatest it'll come back
not the way i won't come back but
that'll come back up we meet the whale
again his name's frank it turns out
i am behind behalf of the ocean
so
off they go
um
they split themselves into two groups
one would sleep one half of us will die
and have a look let's split them down
so one while one group's sleeping the
other one's awake because there's [ __ ]
to do
quotes such as bailing setting tacking
in and trimming the sails so they
actually have to [ __ ] right work
they estimated the food and water would
last 60 days and they figured they could
reach the coast of
south america in 56 days perfect well by
the way i mean four days feels like
plenty feels like putty
now they had some other stuff
some guys grabbed fish hooks there were
candles
a musket two pistols
so they got some stuff not a lot but i
mean not very useful on the ocean yeah
um the wind picks up
and the waves start crashing into the
boat so they're constantly wet for the
first few days right salt water drenches
the bread
well
and the sun is brutal they'll dry that
salt bread out
they give up on the idea of trying to
keep the throat three boats together
like at some point we're gonna get
separated and that's that'll be that
okay
feels like things are bad sometimes they
have to quickly bail water out of the
boats as they would come close to
sinking
that's why you do it yes yes yes yes
on november 28th the other boats heard
george yelling in his boat when they got
close the captain said quote it's at
night time
when they got close the captain said
quote i have been attacked by an unknown
fish and he has stoved my boat
i mean
floating in the ocean at night is just i
mean jesus does it get scarier no i mean
the jungle at night is scary but like
you can feel a little yeah
i've been stoved by an unknown fish
he stopped me
so the unknown fish had attacked with
his jaws
and uh so they couldn't figure out what
kind of fish it was but it was 12 feet
long big big fish just 12 feet long
believed to be a killer whale okay
um
quote
this is what chase said it was quote one
of the killer fish species it was uh
what i would refer to as a killer fish i
thought we called it murder fish shiller
fish
so after hitting the boat once it toyed
with them and then it hit its second
time on the bow and then they started
hitting the fish with they took the
poles that they were using to hold up
the sails and they started hitting the
fish with it
the the [ __ ] killer whale and then
and it took off it was like okay this
isn't fun where are the like killer
whales are are known to be violent but
this i this this mentality oh knowing
after these poachers is great killer
whales are very violent but they're not
just they
they're uh
they're a whale that will [ __ ] with
other animals not even for food like
there are some scientists that
saw a group of killer whales
hitting a stingray and they were just
knocking it up in the air right and they
did it for about 45 minutes and then
they killed it and then they didn't eat
it they just swam off they're like that
was fun no like so they're just yeah
they're they have a good time yeah
that's why they're part white yeah
so um in the morning they made what
repairs they could the boat was still
gosh he's really had a stoving
but was still able to go okay um now the
boats as the days went on were becoming
more frail
and water was flowing in more
how close to peru
super close i'm hoping
super close better be the answer
and they notice over time that more and
more water was getting in as each day
passed
that's bad right
yeah right you don't want you want less
yes yes less
and now they also realize that the bread
they were eating was making them
dehydrated oh you mean the salty bread
interesting what do you think it was i
don't know
i don't want a bread right i'm not a
breader hmm i wonder what this is i'm
not a breadman you know what i mean yeah
sure
um
so
they killed the first turtle on november
30th
chase quote i need not say that the
proposition was hailed with the utmost
enthusiasm yeah well what do you want a
[ __ ] medal everyone's dying and
you're offering a meat let's just say
everyone thought it was a pretty good
idea to eat something before we died
um they drank the blood oh that's good
turtle blood and they cooked the rest in
its shell so they use the shells
absolutely
a storm hit on december 5th but the
boats managed to stay together put some
bread over your head boys
the
leaks increased on the boats quote to an
alarming degree who's pissing in these
it's me but that's i've always been a
piss on the boat guy all right we don't
need you to change
uh they were constantly bailing now so
it's just sure always bailing to keep
the ship up right they're running low on
food and water
okay that's good chase said he now
always kept his loaded pistol with him
in case anyone made a move for the food
or water okay so we're in a good phase
this is where we know we're in a good
phase where someone's ready to start
killing the others over rations that's
good
one day
their boats went through a school of
flying fish and four hit the sail and
fell in the boat and they ate them alive
oh jesus they weren't they weren't so
big
they could fit a whole one into their
mouth so it wasn't huge it was like a
bite-sized right
fish yeah still don't no need to cook it
that's how hungry they are
they don't even split the fish in any
way it's just no just get in your mouth
yes just get in your mouth raw
uh they killed the the last tortoise on
december 11th
that's a bruce willis movie the last
tortoise yeah [ __ ] it's great real good
yeah slow yeah i'm sick of this taurus
what that's a clip from it
[Laughter]
now around this time the winds died down
okay and now they're just
toasting yeah they're just in a boat and
boats just drifting along
they ran out of water
okay they had so much water yeah they
drank it all okay i mean they've been
out there for a little while thirsty
sure uh not actually they haven't been
out there for they've been under a month
but they're you know the the more they
they were getting more and more thirsty
sure yeah no the bread
so
every man tries to put salt water in his
mouth and hold it but it just made them
thirstier that's how you desalinize it
um they drank their own urine oh yes
finally good i'd drink someone else's
just to feel like yeah let's come come
on i'd rather drink mine i mean i'd
drink mine for a while but then after a
while i go guys look let's roll the dice
come on huh
let's do it who wants to spit my mouth
let's have some fun
hey who's pissed am i gonna drink
tonight
um the sun is just brutal it's just
beating down on them
uh one day they they hang off the boat
would you directly into your mouth or
pee into a receptacle well i would want
to pee in a receptacle because i feel
like peeing in my mouth would i would
miss so much
you mean you'd miss so much about your
old life yeah like when you have to do
that
guy this just cups himself i'm just
yearning as this stuff hits my eyes oh i
miss root beer i would definitely i
would definitely be a lay down sort of
oh lay down and pee in your mouth yep
yeah it's interesting yeah
you're right i mean you sacrifice a lot
but yeah if you get it going yeah you
know if you get it
i think that's pretty cool but if you
miss you just you gotta pee in your eyes
and your nose
that's the big problem is your nose
pee up your nose big deal okay
um so
then one day it's so hot that they need
to get in the water to cool down this is
an absolute nightmare
so they hang off the boat and they hang
their bodies in the water
quote no sinner had one of us got on the
outside of the gun whale then he
immediately observed the bottom of the
boat to be covered with a species of
small clam
which upon
being tasted proved a most delicious and
agreeable food there's munching
barnacles yeah there were little clams
on the bottom of the boat i think they
were barnacles yeah they must have been
right i mean that's what barnacles do
what else could it be i don't know
or a small clam sure it's just a bunch
of new clams but yeah but either way so
they're like dinner's on the boat yes so
now they're eating barnacles off the
boat cool living the dream but that
there's not much in a barnacle they were
hungry again after a half hour oh but
they got something in them sure
seems like it's going well and then
there was a lot of water coming into
chase's boat good and then they found
there was a hole in the keel something
stoved it again like they moved some
stuff around there like there's a
[ __ ] hole here all right so someone
saw a hole and just put some stuff over
it which is not cool
so one man tied a rope around his body
went under and hammered a board
on the bottom to fix it while they're
floating along pretty cool
it's tough yeah wouldn't be me no
on i can't i peed in my eyes so much i
can't see
it's still yeah yeah that's still the p
from earlier that was a week ago not a
lot went in the old mouth
a lot went in my eyeballs all right well
i told you he's a cup right i can't find
a cup i could barely see i got piss eyes
you you huh you used to be able to find
cups before you pissed in your eyes
that's why i said get a cup yeah
but then the piss stove in my eyes
the piss stoved right in if i'm gonna be
honest with you we all peed in your eyes
it was uh i didn't think all that was me
yeah i thought it was a lot coming from
random directions yeah
well joke's on you guys why
you wasted all your pee in my eyes
stupid
prank
gotcha
um on december 20th
after a lot of days of this no wind
they see land
uh it's an island about six miles long
and three miles wide peru
anyways
so much smaller than expected
so
now this is like right in between new
zealand and peru
okay
yeah and it's called henderson island or
it was called henderson island it
there's vegetation they can see okay but
not a lot but there's vegetation right
they're 30 days in to their
yeah journey in the boats sure and they
look like you know skeletons are just
yes good they look ripped they look like
they've been on a bit of a barnacle diet
that's right
boy you guys don't smell good well we've
been eating barnacles and drinking piss
it's not gonna be the best
so they get out
on the island and
they couldn't find any water right off
the bat
one guy found some
dripping from some rocks and he put his
mouth against it for like five minutes
but he said not satisfying at all like
not enough it's just a drip sure
so
there's food there they're catching
crabs they're catching some fish
but they're also [ __ ] thirsty out of
their minds i mean what they need is
water yeah
they found
birds eggs they the birds are like going
into holes and they take the birds out
in the eggs and you know suck on them
and eat them or whatever you do sure
maybe cook them yeah
still no water
um so they they
they really can't explore far because
they don't have shoes sure
and so they can't go climbing up into
the island
but they can't find us there should be a
spring going into the water yeah
so for three days
okay they're looking for water right and
then finally
they finally find a spring okay
um they they filled two kegs
and keg stand
and then they discover then they discuss
what they should do let's die
should we feel like we should
do you guys want to play gilligan's
island let's die for sure okay let's die
yeah
so they they're like should we stay here
and wait for a passing ship sure should
they keep going
and so they stay there for four or five
days and then they realize they'd eaten
pretty much everything on the island
okay so so that's kind of a hint that
they have to go right okay
and at least the stuff they can reach
so and they're getting hungry again i
mean there's guys that are now on the
island at the fifth day and he's like i
literally couldn't find any food today
so okay
so they can't stay there at least not
all of them and they decide they're
gonna head for easter island
talk about eggs
oh my god the best yeah
hard to find very when you do when you
do
giant easter egg
three men decide to stay on henderson
island we like the vibe here a lot it's
pretty chill
so
they go i'd stay i'd stay too but
you all can't stay but that was you know
those guys i would have stayed yeah yeah
there's a way even if it's vegetation
you could probably i mean better i'm i'm
like i'm not going back out to the ocean
i'm gonna drink my piss anymore no i'm
done with this there's water here
yeah
we had the baby clams off the bottom of
the boat yeah like we've
gone through all our options we just did
our pants over barnacles so things just
keep in mind where we were at
but they did take some they did did
manage to get some fish and stuff so
they do have some stuff on the boat okay
they can eat
i hope those fish just stove right
through it oh god damn it our dinner
fish have stoved again
uh
so they go out and on january 10th the
second mate
matthew joy dies
so another guy takes over the third boat
okay
he'd been sick the entire voyage so it
wasn't just some starvation he clearly
had something going on right
they um tied a large stone to his feet
and dropped him in the ocean that's nice
they brought they farewell they brought
a large stone on the ship to cook on it
right but okay but what a great
they didn't really need to cook anymore
no well these yeah
so can you just throw them in overboard
yeah but save the stone yeah you
probably would have yeah
eat them i'd bring them along for
potential eating interesting yeah i'm at
that point okay
so they're all pretty bummed you know a
guy died yeah like it's kind of kills
the mood i hope he stoves right through
one of the ships
two days later the boats were separated
at night when a strong wind blew okay
but they keep they keep splitting up and
they're able to get back together for a
little while
is this where that ends no they're not i
don't think they are they i think what
happened
okay so on chase's boat
the rations are getting super low okay
you guys want to do a boat switch
what's in the box just to see what it's
like in your boat you'll see what it's
like
swap but with environments in the boat
it's good
um
so a crew member
eat some bread while chase is sleeping
he'd take some bread okay and then chase
shoots him well he died he points a
pistol out he's about to [ __ ] kill
him he didn't do that but the guy was
just like i couldn't take any words i'm
so sorry that's all
just die like the other guy and he says
he'll never do it again and chase is
like you can't [ __ ] kill this guy
okay
five days later that man gave up
he refused his food oh and he said he
wanted to die and then he laid down in
the boat
and he died wow is that how it can work
that happens more yeah more than but it
just shows you the level of
exhaustion that you and starvation and
at some point you're
you have to fight to live yeah it's the
will yeah i mean it's i we hear about it
on this show all the time and i'm always
like yeah i would not make it to this no
the next part would i would not make it
right i would be the guy who's like no
i'll just
i'm good i'm good i'm gonna do the
forever nap wrap it up i'm in
so they put him in the c
um now
chase's boat is the one that went off
george and the second mate boat are
still together even though the sega
mate's dead okay
um on the 14th the second mate
the what he's the late that's right the
late mate
on the 14th i think the guy's name is
hendrickson so on the 14th henderson's
boat
runs out of provisions okay
and on the 21st george's boat runs out
of provisions good
then on the 23rd charles shorter died on
george's boat okay
and so they ate him
see you knew that was coming what did i
tell you that's how you hold on to the
other guys yeah
yeah you do hold on to this yeah but
that's in chase himself a spicy italian
i think chase's butt has a little more
food sure
okay but they make the the awkward
decision
to eat a pal
and they divide the meat up between the
two boats so awkward
the man the george what's it called uh
charles meat mm-hmm yep yeah a little
ground chuck yes
that's right
the
the rations of human meat didn't last
long between all the dudes i mean just
like if you eat another dude and it's
not fulfilling you're like this is
really kind of the worst of both worlds
yeah you really want to be done in like
with a with a a toothpick and just lean
back yeah ah so it was worth it but
instead you're like we ate a brain
i'm still so hungry
let's drink his piss
this life's not a life
so
but the like i said the rations didn't
last long and then also this weird thing
happened where the more they ate the
hungrier they felt oh girl i've been
there vegas
vegas vegas vegas i can't get full i'm
crazy
two days later isaac shepard died and
they ate him
so we are it's
we're on the ss yum finally for each guy
that dies
there's more
food for you because
you're less one guy yes it's great in
many ways yeah yeah it works it's i mean
i mean it's not great but when you know
you don't want to let uh good be the
enemy agree that's right so yeah one
less mouth to feed
and one more mouth to eat that's right
samurai died the next day and they ate
him too jesus christ i'm starting to get
full
i'm not i'm still hungry i'm starving
yeah
the day after that those two boats
separated so now all the boats are
completely separate okay
things aren't as bad on chase's boat
though
he had become so hungry he tried to eat
some cowhide strapped to the oars
why was there cowhide strapped oh just
it was like i think it keeps the oar
from slipping oh so he was like at the
point where he's like well let's eat
shoes yeah basically yeah quote it only
served to to fatigue my weak jaws oh
yeah because he's trying to chew i mean
seriously
that's not the part you want to try to
all right who wants a little cow skin
i'm exhausted i'm chewing eating a couch
um soon they became too weak to steer
the boat
so they're just drifting right the wind
was also switching back and forth so
they want to go
they're trying to go east but then it
would blow west and then blow east
on february 8th chase quote our
sufferings are now drawing to a close a
terrible death appeared shortly to await
us hunker became violent and outrageous
and we prepared for a speedy release
from our troubles
that's why we need you in
george's boat there's four men left
yum and they realized without any more
food they would all die yeah
you know what i'm starting to think
we're dying right yeah it's not going
great no this is not good at all i feel
like this is insane it's become pretty
clear to me yeah that we've been eating
other guys uh-huh that's desperate
no it's not great i mean when you think
back like that was charles remember the
island we were on yeah
that was there's water there
made some shoes we could have taken the
cow hide off of the oars made some shoes
out of them yeah i could have seen if
those plants are edible but uh
yeah
ted was pretty good though ted was good
ted was good ted was good i would like a
sauce i liked his ass
i didn't try the ass yeah i ate a lot of
that guy's ass i i liked his biceps yeah
ted
you look good you look good too your
eyes are really jaundice and your skin
is leathery i'm just thinking about the
meat on your oh yes you look good in
that way too
if i die
eat the ass you're about to die you've
got to try my ass
i've eaten your ass before no no the
skin oh yeah yes yeah they'll have that
it's not a salad though no you know what
i mean they call it a salad well you're
not doing it right if it doesn't feel
like one that's right
at some point it takes on a greeny
consistency
so
charles ramsdale was a teenager he's 17.
um he comes up with that idea he says
they should draw lots to see who will be
eaten oh my god that is not a game
that's horrible that is terrible well
this is actually
considered a custom of the sea when
things go wrong so why get in the sea if
you're hearing about the customs of the
sea what are you doing getting on a
goddamn boat if you have a job and part
of that job is if things go wrong you
have to eat other guys yeah you're
drawing straws for cannibalism it's a
bad job yeah
okay so he's driving us to see who
they're gonna actually eat
they they agree to do it oh god what a
nightmare and they draw
and
george's cousin owen coffin gets the
short stick uh well we saw this coming
i remember george had promised his aunt
he was going to take care of not him i
said he'd be fine when i said take care
of i mean like
brays
sun cook
so george shouted it owen quote my lad
my lad if you don't like your lot i'll
shoot the first man that touches you and
george offered to take his place he's
like i will take your place and no one's
like no this is my fate this was fair
quote i like it as well as any other
so
ramsdel was owen's best friend
and they drew lots again to see who
would shoot owen and ramsdell was chosen
and then and then there's a very long
process of pause
a very
yeah
long time
awkward right yes the awkward moment
where you're about to kill yourself
we've all had where your best friend's
about to kill your nephew you promised
wouldn't have no harm done upon and eat
him and then devour the flesh of the boy
it's that kind of awkward moment yes yes
so
it looks like you know nothing's going
to happen so owen takes his head and
puts it down on the gun whale so he puts
his head down like i simply just [ __ ]
do this dude stove me and ramsdell shot
him in the head okay hey you missed the
big part of the brain oh boy go again
this is a nightmare
george quote he was soon dispatched and
nothing of him
left dispatched ate his cousin
just
my dear aunt
all i could tell you is you raised a
delicious man
eating him you imagine eating like
eating someone you were just talking to
i bet this this is how you make vegans
just you have to kill your friend and
eat them
well yeah that'll work sucking like a
rib rib meat off of your buddy well now
i'm now i'm back into it eating a little
bit of chad's femur flesh the thing is i
wonder if they have anything to cook
they i mean they do have they have the
rock they have the flanks and the rocks
they're probably cooking i would hope
okay i would hope so on chase's boat
crew member isaac cole is slowly going
insane
what's his deal
he there's mental health issues in the
family so sad yeah
little things will trigger you like and
he doesn't have his pillow dying in the
ocean yeah his medications out oh okay
yeah that makes sense
express scripts doesn't know how to get
it to him uh out there well they keep
looking yeah
so he lays down for a day i'm gonna lay
for a day calmly waiting to die i'm
gonna today i'll die later i'm gonna die
a little later today i'm doing giving up
see i'm doing guilty trying to die about
5 5 30. it doesn't die and then all of a
sudden he stands up whoop and demands a
dinner napkin now i'm ready for my
supper wear going the other way with
this all right tip instead of dying now
i'm ready to eat
[Music]
where's my dinner napkin
[Laughter]
and then he collapsed again that's my
dinner nap getting goodbye again
um they covered him old clothes to keep
him warm but he died a few hours later
they were preparing to put the body in
the sea but chase came up with another
idea
i addressed them on the painful subject
of keeping the body for food yeah
no one disagreed yes what guys come on
let's be honest now the pleasantries are
out of the way we're eating the dead
we're eating ever yeah so what kind of
funeral should we give him oh one that
his family would find yes mouth funeral
yes that's right we will give him what
we call an intestinal destination
through the heavens i'm gonna [ __ ] him
out that's right ladies and gentlemen
we're gonna eat this man
i just
it's one thing to eat your cousin
[ __ ] your cousin out later you don't
know it could be your cousin someone
else too
that's nature baby also
so they quickly
uh began preparing the body now here's
our description of preparing the body um
quote we separated his limbs from his
body
and remember when he was alive 30
seconds ago that was crazy huh
and cut all the flesh from the bones
after which we opened the body took out
his heart and then closed it again
sewed it up as decently as we could and
committed it to the sea
so they basically took all the things
they took all the bones and guts in the
ocean yeah they took all the organs out
and stuff i would be fishing with the
guts yeah that's fair
um we now first commence to satisfy the
immediate
craving of nature from the heart which
we eagerly devoured
and then start with the heart
and then eat sparingly of a few pieces
of the flesh after which we hung up the
remainder cut in thin strips about the
boat to dry in the sun i mean it's just
honest to god i would just be like eat
me now i'm done honest to god start get
keep the knives out let's go
just seeing your the dude strung up
there great it's not great it's a i'm
gonna call this a bummer it's a bummer
it's just really not good and are they
cooking it it does not sound like
they're cooking we made a fire and
roasted some of it to serve us during
the next day oh so the only reason they
cooked it was to make it last a little
bit i don't know why they didn't cook
all of it yeah i don't either i mean
they must have been that hungry but even
then you would think you would want to
like i i mean is that how you make beef
jerky by drying it in the sun i don't
know is that yesterday no you would do i
would more be like a smoker you would
smoke it dry but can't maybe you can't
yeah i'm sure you know that's sun-dried
it's like those tomatoes so it's you
know it's it's morning
yeah
uh unfortunately
um
sunning the mammy
didn't go well i've been there
the next morning they discovered the
flesh had turned green
so like you wasted him
well no because they made a fire and
cooked it which allowed it to keep for
seven days
i can't believe you're
like
eating
green man
yeah
well let's cook the green hem uh
ugh
so
yeah it's not great is it no no no no no
things are far great you're starving
this [ __ ] whale if this whale's
following he's just gonna be like
it's as good as it can get like boy you
really uh really wanted to oil didn't
you
now you're eating your green boy
well there was clearly something wrong
with it because when it turned green
because their limbs swelled over two
days boy look at how good we'd be to eat
right now
like a green michelin man i think i'm at
the incredible hulk i feel like we
should have eaten green tommy did
someone make me mad
on february 18th they saw the sale of a
ship
by the way if you're that ship keep
going yeah [ __ ] these guys hello like a
bunch of white michelin dudes hello
we got this way because i we ate our
green buddy
hello
uh the ship was about seven miles away
so they they sped to cut it off and soon
came alongside the english ship indian
of course they were rescued of course
the indian [ __ ] i mean of course the
english yeah yes we've just creatively
just called this one indian
yes yeah i mean we've stopped pitching
really yes
so they're rescued they've been at sea
for 89 days oh my god how close is peru
near
[ __ ] so george's boat is 300 miles away
from them now only two are alive george
and ramsdale
all they have left to eat are these
others of the last crewmen
by the bones of the last crewman great
bruce willis movie
so they're smashing them all these bones
they're smashing them against the bottom
of the boat in order to get at the
marrow oh my god it's marrow time yeah
you know this is the delicacy
not very filling days go by and they
become obsessed with the bones
dude this is like that kfc commercial uh
okay so they're what do you mean
obsessed with the bones like they're
really just
what are they like all about bone
banging i mean not about bone banging
but they're just like
hugging them like they're into their
bones wow okay
um
so a week after chase's boat was rescued
the american ship dolphin spotted
george's boat
okay
now when they pulled up alongside george
and ramsdale were completely [ __ ] in
the head okay so they've gone mad they
were confused sure and did not celebrate
when the boat pulled up okay
instead they started stuffing the bones
into their pockets sure
sure yep
sure
once safely on the boat
they were quote
sucking the bones of their dead mess
mates which they were loathed to part
with so
so
something strange has happened on the
boat
oh my god well they've just turned into
like they're crazy yeah they're they're
base they've they're in the sun they've
drank seawater they're eating their
friends they're marrow out of their
minds delirious just
just
all right now that you guys are out here
you don't need to eat your friends
anymore no
oh yummy yummy yummy
and yet still this is better than a
carnival ship during covet yes still
this is you your chances of survival are
much higher or i would just say carnival
ship just any any cruise anytime i think
this is still better carnival let's be
straightforward
so
carnival you're gonna eat your friend's
bones
[Applause]
carnival
so the the three survivors from chase's
uh boat are taken with
two
uh val
peroso chile with the two with with
george and ramsdale and they meet up
there
meeting up with them again how are you
guys hanging in there it was not great
so the bones are our bones these are
replaced these bones with our bones
he's still alive
he's still alive at his bones geez can i
ask you questions yes what is going on
with your bones my bones are ready to be
eaten as soon as i get them in all of my
pockets
yes how was your guys's trip it was fine
we just floated around for a little
while um we had turtle we caught some
fish we got some barnacles when you eat
the bones you become the man that you
just ate his bones
try some lick my finger bite it off all
right we didn't have much time
with the whale from before
that's the bird that lives inside of my
body now
hey quick
i want you to take my ribs out without
making a cut on my body
do it i'm going to kill you and eat your
bones i'm fine my parents said
you should take a nap
best friends
we're the best of friends
hmm
okay i'm gonna take off take off good
reunion let's do it once a year ah
so they stayed in chile for a while and
they got better and then they sailed
back to nantucket
i would not be getting on another
vessel
i'd live where i was
the two men who stayed on henderson the
three men who stayed at henderson island
put on 30 pounds lived on shellfish and
birds
at one point they discovered eight
skeletons in a cave which probably
didn't boost their spirits
those would turn out years later they
would realize they were polyphonising
people from like god centuries and
centuries ago okay
but after four months an australian ship
passed by anderson island and rescued
them so they had a great run they had
the best right yeah they didn't eat them
they didn't eat any of their buddies no
they saw bones and they got freaked out
that's how weird their experience was
they found old bones they're like oh my
god this is a bad sign whereas other
people are like these bones are now
money
you understand
do you follow
now even though they had eaten their
fellow crewmen the survivors were
welcome welcome back
in to nantucket without judgment again
like that's what the rules of the sea
are right you eat your buddies when
you're here yep
um good to be in nantucket after we just
lived on man suck it for a couple months
uh but it was weird uh
a crowd gathered on the dock
when they came and when they got off no
one said a word sure and then they
walked alone to their homes without
anybody saying anything perfect that's
the greeting party you want right where
everyone's like those are cannibals
but uh george had a more difficult time
he had eaten his cousin
we all remember who he promised to take
care of oh god dave quit twisting the
knife we get it so for some reason for
the rest of his life his aunt could not
stand stand to be around him what was
her deal she i don't know no she's she
didn't like myself she had a mental
issue too yeah she was just mean i mean
whatever someone eats your kid like
that's a that happens it's the sea he
tasted so good if that's any concept and
i should tell you we ate him right
before the ship crashed we ate owen i
cuddled his bones i if that helps you
still have his bones in my pocket i
saved you some marrow auntie
here's your son
do you want to watch me bite through the
bone of him would that help your
grieving
so owen chase discovered that he had a
14 month old daughter oh god oh god
a few months later in december chase was
back on a ship the florida who first of
all
first of all
first of all first of all who would want
if you're him who wants to get on a ship
second if you're on a ship who wants to
bring this guy third of all if your name
was ship florida you ain't gonna make it
i mean
i guess it's because of the economy like
everything runs off of that's how you
make your money is you go out on a
[ __ ] ship if you're in nantucket like
i don't know move
yeah somewhere else i go to bonesville
he's not the only guy other guys went
like
he had so
chase had three kids and then his wife
died and then he married i'm going to
eat her he married the widow of matthew
joy who was the first guy in the whale
boat to die the one they didn't eat the
one you tried the rock tube that's why
she was married yeah if you'd eaten him
this wouldn't be able to be that's
relationship or would she be like i feel
like you're
he's inside of you and your inside i
feel like it's like the movie heart
condition
that you're bob hoskins but denzel's
heart is still in you when we have sex i
feel like i'm having sex with you and
matthew well i did eat his bones
i wish you'd stop saying that why i know
that that's the only way i can finish
look at my eyes i ate his bones go
oh there she blows
oh i've never felt more like a woman
well i'm marrowless
the end of the ball marrow
uh chase eventually would become a
captain and become wealthy he ended up
marrying four times two of his wives
died
um
[Music]
his entire life after the essex ordeal
he suffered from headaches and
nightmares yeah and when he was old he
started hiding his food in the attic and
then had to be put in an institution for
eight years oh no no no
no oh my god
oh so he did not go to therapy no
that's some weird version of the bone
like he regressed to like bone time yeah
so he was like treating meals like bones
he was like gotta stash it so the other
guys don't find the bones i mean
he he they clearly would all have
terrible ptsd and there was no
there was no like solution but that
might have been why he went back out on
the water because it was his only way to
deal with like he's the only place
he's sitting still he's getting the
terror dream and his wife couldn't hear
it yeah i mean he can sitting still in
your house is the terrifying part but if
you're uh you know alone with your
thoughts is that nightmare and so
he was institutionalized for eight years
he got out
and he died in night and honey where are
those meals i had i feel way better
he died in 1889.
years later
the third boat was discovered on ducey
island with three skeletons on board
so i think all that food
george went back out to sea as captain
of the whaling ship two brothers
so another one it used to be called the
cousins
[Applause]
we should call it one brother
or
edible pals
[Laughter]
but the ship wrecked on a coral reef two
years later and george became labeled a
jonah which was someone who was unlucky
at sea and no ship owners would give him
another ship hey i'm fine fine with this
label yeah that's i'm not going to do it
the thing where i don't eat people by
the way he hits coral i'd be like he's
getting closer
he's getting better at this he is it's
an improvement he didn't need any of his
buddies
so george spent the rest of his life in
nantucket working as the village knight
watchman
on the anniversary of the wreck do you
see anybody walking by here
i've um sorry i'm just finishing off a
rib biscuit um
no nobody's uh walked by
here in uh hours so uh i'll see you
tomorrow what's on the barbecue huh
what's on the barbecue what are you
barbecuing some uh just uh a bunch of um
deer venison venison been a man man
venice venison
bandier
a man
a deer oh my god oh dear i cooked a man
sorry oh man i've made a deer there it
is that's what it is it's gear yeah
because it seems like what like a man
you sound crazy but that's a foot yeah
of course
it's called a hoove it looks like a man
foot well it's a
man's foot
okay
that's why but it's called a hoof when
you deal with it like this a lot of
times when you cook up these things they
foot out you never heard that expression
a lot of the deer needle foot out on you
or in this case foot foot out you know
or hand out a little bit too
i'm uh
the ribs are the same
the ribs are deer i mean they're not the
same the ribs are the deer yeah you know
what i shot it with a bow and a marrow
arrow what the hell screw you i'll see
you i'll see you around town do you
eat guy
no yeah name me name it name a name name
it a name for me that's what i say yeah
okay i'm gonna back and walk backwards
yes yes yes yes yes thank you thank us
for
yes dear yes yep yes
take care you're following yes don't yes
it's hunting it's okay i'm running
backwards yes running i'm rotting after
you and i'm okay i'm stabbing you in the
heart
put you on the grill that was on the
grill was a man it's a man on the ground
now i know yes now i know you will join
him foot gave it away yes you idiot that
doesn't happen naturally i don't know
why you can't putting out isn't even a
thing you idiot i can't believe you
convinced me that was a deer
it looks like a human foot
i died
there it is
and come on hi hurry
i am full of you're on the grill now
poison yes oh damn i'll still eat
uh so on the anniversary of the wreck of
the essex george would lock himself in
his room every time and fast
and july it's just it's it's
just imagine counseling
like if it existed at the level that
he'd be like i'm actually able to
understand some of these things now
instead he's like well i'm off to the
closet for the anniversary won't come
out for 24. i'll be starving when i do
now
the year after they returned um
owen chase
with a ghost writer published a book
about what happened okay explained it
all the eating the people and like
didn't hold back sure and then in july
1852 herman melville published
inspired by the story of the essex jesus
christ
and he came that month to nantucket
and he met his last night there he met
george pollard jr
and they talked and melville wrote that
george was the quote most impressive man
though holy unassuming even humble that
i ever encountered
what's he supposed to say hockey
so i took his life
from him for mine
wow
so melville just heard the story and was
just like yeah he read it he read the
story i was like this would be great
yeah
uh
and actually it's crazy because
i mean you think about like moby dick
people are like imagine but there was a
whale that was like
imagine
yeah
george died in
and moby dick received mixed reviews and
did not sell well he tried to write a
few more novels but none sold and he
eventually lived as a recluse while
working as a customs inspector in new
york city melville drank and uh two of
his sons died so he had a rough life he
abandoned novels and wrote poetry
not a lot of people know the first line
of moby dick was alas poor burgers
they call him yummy
they call him kebab
sources narrative the most extraordinary
and distressing shipwreck of the whale
ship essex by
owen chase uh smithsonian magazine atlas
obscura
um amusing planet
god damn
cassie for me cannibalism is where i
it's just it is it is the hardest
position to put yourself in to decide if
what would you do
i would eat i would eat it you dave i'm
not talking about you i'm talking about
you dude third day yeah you did bro we
hung out with kangaroos and within 24
hours you're like they're delicious yeah
yeah so you're a psychopath but i'm
talking about like regular humans
well like for me
a big part of me feels like i'd be the
guy who'd be like just i'm going to die
like i'm going to just roll over and die
you'd rather die than eat
i think i would just i think i don't
think i would have that instinct to be
like
i think i would be like i won't be able
to live a life when i'm you know what i
mean i don't think you're thinking that
clearly
yeah you're probably not but i still
would be like i don't so many people
have done it like almost in these
stories people always eat other people i
know and it's [ __ ] crazy so you would
get there
in this story there are a couple people
who just give in
i mean there's the guy who's just like
i'm dying pretending i was like the
first guy if he had had a chance to eat
other people he might not have he might
have been like oh i'll eat a frank
i just i just don't think i'd eat them i
think everybody would i just don't think
i would well we're gonna try it out i
just i would love to be in that position
i really think i would just i think i
would i'm at the i just i think i'm at
the point where i'm just i'm more
comfortable dying than going through the
pain of the future i think i'm just
there
i think i want like with the second that
it all the second that the major climate
collapse begins i just i feel like i'll
be like goodbye you're not gonna be like
the people who have the house and the
the road no
no i don't think i i mean maybe i will
be but even then what if as soon as my
utopia gets smashed to some degree i'll
be like just yeah i'll be the guy who's
like go on without me you know what i
mean i'll be like i'll distract him i'll
be michael caine and children of men
i'll be the guy's like ella yes you
thought we'd do this you know and i'd
just die yeah
thought you'd come here
hello yeah so i think i'd be that guy
all right that's fair yeah what about a
cat or a dog
uh no
no
no because i already see where you're
headed so [ __ ]
no
he'll eat me okay do you understand
he'll eat me
hmm
yeah
or we'll eat each other
he'll eat you i'm fine with it
we're all fine with it yeah that's
that's my
if my fate is to be eight
great
oh yeah my dogs would eat me
yeah no
uh your dogs i know i don't know people
are always i always think about the guys
who were out in the boat
like you know their ship crashed and
they got out in their boat and then they
ate each other and there was one guy
left and then he just starved to death
your last thought would be like well
that wasn't [ __ ] worth it or what
about like
what about okay you're you're
you're at the point where you're like
okay look todd's dead
[ __ ] it i'm just gonna eat him and you
eat him and then hey
we saw some smoke oh my god oh my god no
what are you doing nothing you know what
i mean
it's like yeah that's what i would fear
yeah yeah yeah someone coming right away
it would be the worst just as soon as
you like you're just you're just chewing
on an arm jesus christ what's wrong with
you oh hi you got i didn't
oh my god is the cabin right there yeah
it's right there oh this is a driveway
i just there's a lowe's over there i
thought what are you doing i have been
here a while it's a parking lot and i
thought it's your problem i just didn't
there's an open sabaro it was hard to
get a what's your deal brain around what
was happening i ate a dude
yeah but that burger king is 24 hours oh
[ __ ] yeah
by the way you're basically eating
people if you go there so anyway that's
the same thing well okay actually it
might be better off eating you're better
off eating him rather than having the
sabaro sausage i'll be honest yeah it's
it's actually made from him i like that
so there we go
uh well normal stuff always cute to eat
is it yes it's my that's about the
mantra that's gotten me quite far
it's always good to eat
um so anyway go vegan i guess i don't
know anymore i don't know what the
answer is to anything
i don't know i'm starting to think we
might have to just eat
eat everything and see what's under
earth maybe we can maybe we can eat
through the mantle and just find out
what's in the core of this [ __ ] huh
who knows
start uh yeah just uh i think
but if we factory farmed humans
great solution yes great solution we
have we have the numbers yep let's start
meeting peoples oh that's how you solve
it it's just like smelling green just
turn them into you know little bars yes
yeah yeah i'm all for it thank you all
right great to meet you sir nice to meet
you thank you for coming great hi ted
talk great meeting people great to meet
you yes
so good meeting him
so good to meet you